PROFESSOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
So welcome back.
So we are now moving
to a new chapter, which
is going to have a little
more of a statistical flavor
when it comes to designing
methods, all right?
Because if you
think about it, OK--
some of you have probably
attempted problem number two
in the problem set.
And you realize that maximum
likelihood estimators does not
give you super trivial
estimators, right?
I mean, when you have an n theta
theta, then the thing you get
is not something you could have
guessed before you actually
attempted to solve that problem.
And so, in a way, we've seen
already sophisticated methods.
However, in many instances, the
maximum likelihood estimator
was just an average.
And in a way, even if
we had this confirmation
for maximum likelihood that
indeed that was the estimator
that maximum likelihood
would spit out,
and that our intuition
was therefore pretty good,
most of the statistical analysis
or use of the central limit
theorems, all these
things actually
did not come in the
building of estimator,
in the design of the
estimator, but really
in the analysis
of the estimator.
And you could say,
well, if I know already
that the best estimator
is the average,
I'm just going to
use the average.
I don't have to, basically,
quantify how good it is.
I just know it's
the best I can do.
We're going to talk about tests.
And we're going to talk about
parametric hypothesis testing.
So you should view this
as-- parametric means,
well, it's about a parameter,
like we did before.
And hypothesis testing is on
the same level as estimation.
And on the same
level as estimator
will be the word "test," OK?
And when we're going
to devise a test,
we're going to actually
need to understand
random fluctuations that arise
from the central limit theorem
better, OK?
It's not just going
to be in the analysis.
It's also going to
be in the design.
And everything we've been
doing before in understanding
the behavior of an
estimator is actually
going to come in
and be extremely
useful in the actual
design of tests, OK?
So as an example, I want to talk
to you about some real data.
I will not study this data.
But this data actually exist.
You can find it
on R. And so, it's
the data from the so-called
credit union Cherry Blossom
Run, which is a 10 mile race.
It takes place
every year in D.C.
It seems that some of the
years are pretty nice.
In 2009, there were about
15,000 participants.
Pretty big race.
And the average running time
was 103.5 minutes, all right?
So about an hour and a
half or a little bit more.
And so, you can ask the
following question, right?
This is actual data, right?
103.5 actually averaged the
running time for all of 15,000.
Now, this in practice, may not
be something very suitable.
And you might want to
just sample a few runners
and try to understand
how they're
behaving every
year without having
to collect the entire data set.
And so, you could ask
the question, well,
let's say my budget is to
ask for maybe 10 runners
what their running time was.
I still want to be
able to determine
whether they were running
faster in 2012 than in 2009.
Why do I put 2012, and not 2016?
Well, because the data set
for 2012 is also available.
So if you are interested
and you know how to use R,
just go and have fun with it.
So to answer this question, what
we do is we select n runners,
right?
So n is a moderate number that's
more manageable than 15,000.
From the 2012 race at random.
That's where the random variable
is going to come from, right?
That's where we actually inject
randomness in our problem.
So remember this
is an experience.
So really in a way, the
runners are the omegas.
And I'm interested in
measurements on those guys.
So this is how I have
a random variable.
And this random verbal here is
measuring their running time.
OK.
If you look at the data
set, you have all sorts
of random variables
you could measure
about those random runners.
Country of origin.
I don't know, height,
age, a bunch of things.
OK.
Here, the random
variable of interest
being the running time.
OK.
Everybody understand
what the process is?
OK.
So now I'm going to have to
make some modeling assumptions.
And here, I'm
actually pretty lucky.
I actually have all the
data from a past year.
I mean, this is not the data
from 2012, which I also have,
but I don't use.
But I can actually use past
data to try to understand what
distribution do I have, right?
I mean, after all,
running time is going
to be rounded to something.
Maybe I can think of it as
a discrete random variable.
Maybe I can think of it as the
exponential random variable.
Those are positive numbers.
I mean, there's many
kind of running times
that could come up to mind.
Many kind of distributions
I could think
of for this modeling part.
But it turns out
that if you actually
plug the histogram of those
running times for all 15,000
runners in 2009,
you actually are
pretty happy to
see that it really
looks like a bell-shaped
curve, which suggest
that this should be a Gaussian.
So what you go on to do
is you estimate the mean
from past observations, which
was actually 103.5, as we said.
You submit the
variance, which was 373.
And you just try to
superimpose the curve
with this one, which is a
Gaussian PDF with mean 103.5
and variants 373.
And you see that they
actually look very much alike.
And so here, you're
pretty comfortable to say
that the running time actually
is Gaussian distribution.
All right?
So now I know that
the x1 to xn, I'm
going to say they're
Gaussian, OK?
I still need to
specify two parameters.
So what I want to know is,
is the distribution the same
from past years, right?
So I want to know if the random
variable that I'm looking
for-- if I, say, pick one.
Say, x1.
Does it have the same
distribution in 2012
that it did in 2009?
OK.
And so, the question
is, is x1 has
a Gaussian distribution with
mean 103.5 and variance 373?
Is that clear?
OK.
So this question that calls
for a yes or no answer
is a hypothesis testing problem.
I am testing a hypothesis.
And this is the basis
of basically all
of data-driven
scientific inquiry.
You just ask questions.
You formulate a
scientific hypothesis.
Knocking down this gene is going
to cure melanoma, is this true?
I'm going to collect.
I'm going to try.
I'm to observe some patients on
which I knock down this gene.
I'm going to collect
some measurements.
And I'm going to try to answer
this yes/no question, OK?
It's different
from the question,
what is the mean running
time for this year?
OK.
So this hypothesis
testing is testing
if this hypothesis is true.
The hypothesis in common
English we just said,
were runners running faster?
All right?
Anybody could formulate
this hypothesis.
Now, you go to a statistician.
And he's like, oh,
what you're really
asking me is x1 has a Gaussian
distribution with mean
less than 103.5 and
variance 373, right?
That's really the question that
you ask in statistical terms.
And so, if you're asking if
this was the same as before,
there's many ways it could
not be the same as before.
There's basically
three ways it could not
be the same as before.
It could be the case that x1
is in expectation to 103.5
So the expectation has changed.
Or the variance has changed.
Or the distribution has changed.
I mean, who knows?
Maybe runners are now just all
running holding their hands.
And it's like now a point
mass at 1 given point.
OK.
So you never know what
could [INAUDIBLE]..
Now of course, if you
allow for any change,
you will find change.
And so what you have to do is
to factor in as much knowledge
as you can.
Make as many
modeling assumptions,
so that you can
let the data speak
about your particular question.
Here, your particular question
is, are they running faster?
So you're only really asking a
question about the expectation.
You really want to know if
the expectation has changed.
So as far as you're
concerned, you're
happy to make the
assumption that the rest has
been unchanged.
OK.
And so, this is the
question we're asking.
Is the expectation
now less than 103.5?
Because you specifically
asked whether runners were
going faster this year, right?
They tend to go faster rather
than slower, all right?
OK.
So this is the question we're
asking in mathematical terms.
So first, when I did that, I
need to basically fix the rest.
And fixing the rest
is actually part
of the modeling assumptions.
So I fixed my
variance to be 373.
OK?
I assume that the
variance has not
changed between 2009 and 2012.
Now, this is an assumption.
It turns out it's wrong.
So if you look at
the data from 2012,
this is not the
correct assumption.
But I'm just going
to make it right now
for the sake of argument, OK?
And also the fact
that it's Gaussian.
Now, this is going to be
hard to violate, right?
I mean, where did this
bell-shaped curve come from?
Well, it's just natural when you
just measure a bunch of things.
The central limit
theorem appears
in the small things of nature.
I mean, that's the bedtime story
you get about the central limit
theorem.
And that's why the bell-shaped
curve is everywhere in nature.
It's the sum of little
independent things
that are going on.
And this Gaussian assumption,
even if I wanted to relax it,
there's not much else I can do.
It is pretty robust
across the years.
All right.
So the only thing
that we did not fix
is the expectation of x1, which
now I want to know what it is.
And since I don't know what it
is, I'm going to call it mu.
And it's going to be a variable
of interest, all right?
So it's just a number mu.
Whatever this is I can try
to estimate it, maybe using
maximum likelihood estimation.
Probably using the average,
because this is Gaussian.
And we know that the
maximum likelihood
estimator for a Gaussian
is just the average.
And now we only want to test
if mu is equal to 103.5,
like it was in 2009.
Or on the contrary, if
mu is not equal to 103.5.
And more specifically,
if mu is actually
strictly less than 103.5.
That's the question you ask.
Now, why am I in writing
mu equal to 103.5 or is
less than 103.5
and equal to 103.5
versus not equal to 103.5?
It's because since you asked
me a more precise question,
I'm going to be able to give
you a more precise answer.
And so, if your question
is very specific--
are they running faster?
I'm going to factor
that in what I write.
If you just ask
me, is it the same?
I'm going to have to write,
or is it different than 103.5?
And that's less
information about what
you're looking for, OK?
So by making all these
modeling assumptions--
the fact that the
variance doesn't change,
the fact that it's
still Gaussian--
I've actually reduced
the number of.
And I put numbers in quotes,
because this is still
an infinite of them.
But I'm limiting
the number of ways
the hypothesis can be violated.
The number of possible
alternative realities
for this hypothesis, all right?
For example, I'm
saying there's no way
mu can be larger than 103.5.
I've already
factored that in, OK?
It could be.
But I'm actually just going
to say that if it's larger,
all I'm going to be able to tell
you is that it's not smaller.
I'm not going to
be able to tell you
that it's actually larger, OK?
And the only way it
can be rejected now.
The only way I can
reject my hypothesis
is if x belongs to very specific
family of distributions.
If it has a distribution
which is Gaussian
with mean mu and variance of
373 for mu, which is less 103.5.
All right?
So we started with
basically was x1--
so that's the reality.
x1 follows n 103.5 373, OK?
And this is everything
else, right?
So for example,
here is x follows
some exponential, 0.1, OK?
This is just another
distribution here.
Those are all the
possible distributions.
What we said is we said,
OK, first of all, let's just
keep only those Gaussian
distributions, right?
And second, we said, well, among
those Gaussian distributions,
let's only look at
those that have-- well,
maybe this one should
be at the boundary--
let's only look at
the Gaussians here.
So this guy here are
all the Gaussians
with mean mu and variance 373
for mu less than 103.5, OK?
So when you're going
to give me data,
I'm going to be able to
say, well, am I this guy?
Or am I one of those guys?
Rather than searching
through everything.
And the more you search
the easier for you
to find something that fits
better the data, right?
And so, if I allow
everything possible,
then there's going
to be something
that just by pure randomness is
actually going to look better
for the data, OK?
So for example, if I draw
10 random variables, right?
If n is equal to 10.
And let's say they take
10 different values.
Then it's actually more
likely that those guys
come from a discrete
distribution that
takes each of these values
with probability 1 over 10,
than actually some Gaussian
random variable, right?
That would be perfect.
I can actually explain it.
If the 10 numbers
I got were say--
let's say I collect
3, 90, 95, and 102.
Then the most likely
distribution for those guys
is the discrete
distribution that
takes three values, 91
with probability 1/3, 95
with probability 1/3, and
102 with probably 1/3, right?
That's definitely the most
likely distribution for this.
So if I allowed this,
I would say, oh no.
This is not distributed
according to that.
It's distributed according
to this very specific
distribution, which is
somewhere in the realm
of all possible
distributions, OK?
So now we're just going to try
to carve out all this stuff
by making our assumptions.
OK.
So here in this
particular example,
just make a mental note
that what we're doing
is that I actually--
a little birdie told me that the
reference number is 103.5, OK?
That was the thing I'm
actually looking for.
In practice, it's
actually seldom the case
that you have this reference
for yourself to think of, right?
Maybe here, I just happen
to have a full data
set of all the runners of 2009.
But if I really just
asked you, I said,
were runners faster
in 2012 than in 2009?
Here's $10 to perform
your statistical analysis.
What you're probably going to
do is called maybe 10 runners
from 2012, maybe 15
runners from 2009,
ask them and try to
compare their mean.
There's no standard reference.
You would not be able to
come up with this 103.5,
because these data maybe is
expensive to get or something.
OK.
So this is really more of
the standard case, all right?
Where you really compare
two things with each other,
but there's no actual
ground truth number
that you're comparing it to.
OK.
So we'll come back
to that in a second.
I'll tell you what the
other example looks like.
So let's just stick
to this example.
I tell you it's 103.5, OK?
Let's try to have our
intuition work the same way.
We said, well,
averages worked well.
The average, tell me,
of over these 10 guys
should tell me what
the mean should be.
So I can just say,
well x bar is going
to be close to the true mean
by the law of large number.
So I'm going to decide whether
x bar is less than 103.5.
And conclude that in this case,
indeed mu is less than 103.5,
because those two
quantities are close, right?
I could do that.
The problem is that this
could go pretty wrong.
Because if n is
small, then I know
that xn bar is not equal to mu.
I know that xn bar
is close to mu.
But I also know that
there's pretty high chance
that it's not equal to mu.
In particular, I know it's going
to be somewhere at 1 over root
n away from mu, right?
1 over root n being the
root coming from what?
CLT, right?
That's the root n that comes
from CLT. In blunt words,
CLT tells me the
mean is at distance
1 over root n from the
expectation, pretty much.
That's what it's telling.
So 1 over root n.
If I have 10 people in
there, 1 over root 10
is not a huge number, right?
It's like 1/3 pretty much.
So 1/3 103.5.
If the true mean
was actually 103.4,
but my average was telling
me it's 103.4 plus 1/3,
I would actually come to two
different conclusions, right?
So let's say that mu
is equal to 103.4, OK?
So you're not supposed
to know this, right?
That's the hidden truth.
OK.
Now I have n is equal to 10.
So I know that x
bar n minus 103.4
is something of the order of
1 over the square root of 10,
which is of the
order of, say, 0.3.
OK.
So here, this is
all hand wavy, OK?
But that's what the central
limit theorem tells me.
What it means is
that it is possible
that x bar n is actually
equal to is actually
equal to 103.4 plus 0.3,
which is equal to 103.7.
Which means that while the truth
is that mu is less than 103.5,
then I would conclude that
mu is larger than 103.5, OK?
And that's because I have
not been very cautious, OK?
So what we want to do is
to have a little buffer
to account for the
fact that xn bar is not
a precise value for the true mu.
It's something that's 1
over root n away from you.
And so, what we want is
the better heuristic that
says, well, if I want
to conclude that I'm
less than 103.5, maybe I
need to be less than 103.5
minus a little buffer that goes
to 0 as my sample size goes
to infinity.
And actually, that's what the
law of large number tells me.
The central limit
theorem actually
tells me that this
should be true,
something that goes to
0 as n goes to infinity
and the rate 1
over root n, right?
That's basically what the
central limit theorem tells me.
So to make this
intuition more precise,
we need to understand
those fluctuations.
We need to actually
put in something
that's more precise than
these little wiggles here, OK?
We need to actually have the
central limit theorem come in.
So here is the example
of comparing two groups.
So pharmaceutical
companies use hypothesis
testing to test if a
drug is efficient, right?
That's what they do.
They want to know,
does my new drug work?
And that's what the Federal
Drug Administration office
is doing on a daily basis.
They ask for extremely well
regulated clinical trials
on a thousand people,
and check, does this drug
make a difference?
Did everybody die?
Does it make no difference?
Should people pay $200 for
a pill of sugar, right?
So that's what people
are actually asking.
So to do so, of course, there
is no ground truth about--
so there's actually
a placebo effect.
So it's not like actually
giving a drug that does not work
is going to have no
effect on patients.
It will have a small effect,
but it's very hard to quantify.
We know that it's there, but
we don't know what it is.
And so rather than saying,
oh the ground truth
is no improvement, the ground
truth is the placebo effect.
And we need to measure
what the placebo effect is.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to split our
patients into two groups.
And there's going to
be what's called a test
group and a control group.
So the word test here is
used in a different way
than hypothesis testing.
So we'll just call it
typically the drug group.
And so, I will refer to
mu drug for this guy, OK?
Now, this let's say this
is a cough syrup, OK?
And when you have a
cough syrup, the way
you measure the efficacy
of a cough syrup
is to measure how many times
you cough per minute, OK?
And so, if I define
mu control the number
of expectoration per hour.
So just the expected
number, right?
This is the number I don't know,
because I don't have access
to the entire population
of people that will ever
take this cough syrup.
And so, I will call it mu
control for the control group.
So those are the people who
have been actually given just
like sugar, like maple syrup.
And mu drug are those people who
are given the actual syrup, OK?
And you can imagine that maybe
maple syrup will have an effect
on expectorations per hour just
because, well, it's just sweet
and it helps, OK?
And so, we don't know what
this effect is going to be.
We just want to measure
if the drug is actually
having just a better
impact on expectorations
per hour than the just
pure maple syrup, OK?
So what we want to know is if
mu drug is less than mu control.
That would be enough.
If we had access to
all the populations
that will ever take
the syrup for all ages,
then we would just measure,
did this have an impact?
And even if it's a slightly
ever so small impact,
then it's good to
release this cough syrup,
assuming that it has no side
effects or anything like this,
because it's just better
than maple syrup, OK?
The problem is that we
don't have access to this.
And we're going to have to make
this decision based on samples
that give me imprecise knowledge
about mu drug and mu control.
So in this case,
unlike the first case
where we compared an
unknown expected value
to have a fixed number, which
was one of the 103.5, here,
we're just comparing two unknown
numbers with each other, OK?
So there's two
sources of randomness.
Trying to estimate
the first one.
And trying to estimate
the second one.
Before I move on, I just
wanted to tell you I apologize.
One of the graders was not able
to finish grading his problem
sets for today.
So for those of you who are here
just to pick up their homework,
feel free to leave now.
Even if you have a name tag, I
will pretend I did not read it.
OK.
So I'm sorry.
You'll get it on Tuesday.
And this will not happen again.
OK.
So for the clinical
trials, now I'm
going to collect information.
I'm going to collect the
data from the control group.
And I'm going to collect data
from the test group, all right?
So my control group here.
I don't have to collect the same
number of people in the control
group than in the drug group.
Actually, for cough syrup,
maybe it's not that important.
But you can imagine
that if you think
you have the cure to a
really annoying disease,
it's actually hard to tell
half of the people you
will get a pill of nothing, OK?
People tend to want
to try the drug.
They're desperate.
And so, you have to have
this sort of imbalance
between who is getting the drug
and who's not getting the drug.
And people have to qualify
for the clinical trials.
There's lots of
fluctuations that
affect what the final numbers
of people who are actually
going to get the drug and
are going to get the control
is going to be.
And so, it's not easy for you
to make those two numbers equal.
You'd like to have those
numbers equal if you can,
but not necessarily.
And by the way, this is all part
of some mystical science called
"design of experiments."
And in particular,
you can imagine
that if one of the series
had higher variants,
you would want to like
more people in this group
than the other group.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So when we're
subtracting [INAUDIBLE]
something that [INAUDIBLE] 0
[INAUDIBLE] to be satisfied.
So that's on
purpose [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's on purpose.
And I'll come to that
in a second, all right?
So basically, we're
going to make it
if your answer is, is this true?
We're going to make it as hard
as possible, but no harder
for you to say yes
to this answer.
Because, well, we'll see why.
OK, so now we have two set
of data, the x's and the y's.
The x's are the
ones for the drug.
And the y's are the data that I
collected from the people, who
were just given a placebo, OK?
And so, they're all
IID random variables.
And here, since it's the
number of expectorations,
I'm making a blunt
modeling assumption.
I'm just going to
say it's Poisson.
And it's characterized only by
the mean mu drug or the mean mu
control, OK?
I've just made an
assumption here.
It could be something different.
But let's say it's a
Poisson distribution.
So now what I want to know
is to test whether mu drug is
less than mu control.
We said that already.
But the way we said it before
was not as mathematical
as it is now.
Now we're actually making
a test on the parameters
of Poisson distribution.
Whereas before, we
were just making test
on expected numbers, OK?
So the heuristic-- again, if we
try to apply the heuristic now.
Rather than comparing mu x
bar drug to some fixed number,
I'm actually comparing x
bar drug to some control.
But now here, I need to have
something that accounts for,
not only the fluctuations
of x bar drug,
but also for the fluctuations
of x bar control, OK?
And so, now I need
something that
goes to 0 when all those
two things go to infinity.
And typically, it should go to
zero with 1 over root of n drug
and 1 over square
root of n control, OK?
That's what the central
limit theorem for both x bar
drug and x bar control.
Two central limit theorems
are actually telling.
OK.
And then we can conclude
that this happens.
And as you said, we're
trying to make it
a bit harder to conclude this.
Because let's face it.
If we were actually using
two simple heuristic, right?
For simplicity, right?
So I can rewrite x bar drug
less than x bar control
minus this something
that goes to 0.
I can write it as x bar drug
minus x bar control less
than something negative, OK?
This little something, OK?
So now let's look at those guys.
This is the difference
of two random variables.
From the central
limit theorem, they
should be approximately
Gaussian each.
And actually, we're
going to think
of them as being independent.
There's no reason why the
people in the control group
should have any effect
on what's happening
to the people in the test group.
Those people probably
don't even know each other.
And so, when I look at this,
this should look like n 0
with some mean
and some variants,
let's say I don't
know what it is, OK?
The mean I actually know.
It's mu drug minus
mu control, OK?
So if they were to plot
the PDF of this guy,
it would look like this.
I would have something
which is centered
at mu drug minus mu control.
And it would look like this, OK?
Now let's say that mu drug is
actually equal to mu control.
That this pharmaceutical
company is a huge scam.
And they really are trying
to sell bottled corn
syrup for $200 a pop, OK?
So this is a huge scam.
And the true things are
actually equal to 0.
So this thing is really
centered about 0, OK?
Now, if were not to do
this, then basically, half
of the time I would
actually come up
with a distribution
that's above this value.
And half of the time I
would have something that's
below this value, which would
mean that half of the scams
would actually go through
FDA if I did not do this.
So what I'm trying to
do is to say, well, OK.
You have to be here, so
that there is actually
a very low probability
that just by chance
you end up being here.
And we'll make all the
statements extremely precise
later on.
But I think the
drug thing makes it
interesting to see why
you're making it hard,
because You don't
want to allow people
to sell a thing like that.
Before we go more into the
statistical thinking associated
to tests, let's just
see how we would
do this quantification, right?
I mean after all, this
is what we probably
are the most comfortable
with at this point.
So let's just try
to understand this.
And I'm going to make the
statisticians favorite test,
which is the thing that
obviously you do at home all
the time every time
you get a new quarter,
is testing whether it's
a fair coin or not.
All right?
So this test, of course,
exists only in textbooks.
And I actually did
not write this slide.
I was lazy to just
replace all this stuff
by the Cherry Blossom Run.
So you have a coin.
Now you have 80
observations, x1 to x80.
So n is equal to 80.
I have x1, xn, IID, Bernoulli p.
And I want to know if
I have a fair coin.
So in mathematical
language, I want
to know if p is equal to 1/2.
Let's say this is
just the heads, OK?
And a biased coin?
Well, maybe you
would potentially
be interested
whether it's biased
one direction or the other.
But not being a fair
coin is already somewhat
of a discovery, OK?
And so, you just want to know
whether p is equal to 1/2
or p is not equal to 1/2, OK?
Now, if I were to apply the
very naive first example
to not reject this hypothesis.
If I run this thing
80 times, I need
to see exactly 40
heads and 40 tales.
Now this is very unlikely
to happen exactly.
You're going to have close to
40 heads and close to 40 tails,
but how close should
those things be?
OK?
And so, the little
something is going
to be quantified by
exactly this, OK?
So now here, let's say that my
experiment gave me 54 heads.
That's 54?
Yeah.
Which means that my xn bar
is 54 over 80, which is 0.68.
All right?
So I have this estimator.
Looks pretty large, right?
It's much larger than
0.5, so it does look like,
and my mom would
certainly conclude,
that this is a
biased coin for sure,
because she thinks I'm tricky.
All right.
So the question is, can
this be due to chance?
Can this be due to chance alone?
Like what is the likelihood
that a fair coin would actually
end up being 54 times
on heads rather than 40?
OK?
And so, what we do
is we say, OK, I
need to understand, what is
the distribution of the number
of times it comes on heads?
And this is going
to be a binomial,
but it's a little
annoying to play with.
So we're going to use the
central limit theorem that
tells me that xn
bar minus p divided
by square root of p1 minus p
is approximately distributed
as an n01.
And here, since
n is equal to 80,
I'm pretty safe that this
is actually going to work.
And I can actually
use [INAUDIBLE],,
and put xn bar here.
[INAUDIBLE] tells me
that this is OK to do.
All right.
So now I'm actually
going to compute this.
So here, I know this.
This is square root of 80.
This is a 0.68.
What is this value here?
We'll talk about it.
Well, we're trying to
understand what happens
if it is a fair coin, right?
So if fair, then p is
equal to 0.5, right?
So what I want to know
is, what is the likelihood
that a fair coin
would give me 0.68?
Let me finish.
All right.
What is the likelihood
that a fair coin will
allow me to do this, so I'm
actually allowed to plug-in p
to be 0.5 here?
Now, your question is, why
do I not plug-in p to be 0.5?
But you can.
All right.
I just want to make you plug-in
p at one specific point,
but you're absolutely right.
OK.
Let's forget about your
question for one second.
So now I'm going to have to
look at xn bar minus 0.5 divided
by xn bar 1 minus xn bar.
Then this thing is
approximately Gaussian and 0,1
if the coin is fair.
Otherwise, I'm going to have
a mean which is not zero here.
If the coin is something else,
whatever I get here, right?
Let's just write
it for one second.
Let's do it.
So what is the
distribution of this if p--
so that's p is equal to 0.5.
OK?
Now if p is equal to 0.6,
then this thing is just, well,
I know that this is equal
to square root of n xn
bar minus 0.6,
divided by xn bar 1
minus xn in the bar
squared root, plus--
well, now the difference.
Is So square root
of n, 0.6 minus
0.5, divided by square root of
xn bar 1 minus xn bar, right?
Now if p is equal to 0.6,
then this guy is n 0,1,
but this guy is
something different.
This is just a number that
depends on square root of n.
It's actually pretty large.
So if I want to use the
fact that this guy has
a normal distribution, I need
to plug-in the true value here.
Now, the implicit question
that I got was the following.
It says, well, if you know
what p is, then what's
actually true is also this.
If p is equal to
0.5, then since I
know that root n xn bar minus
p divided by square root of p 1
minus p is some n
0, 1, it's also true
that square root of
n xn bar minus 0.5
divided by square root of 0.5
1 minus 0.5 is n 0,1, right?
I know what p is.
I'm just going to
make it appear.
OK.
And so, what's actually
nice about this particular
[INAUDIBLE] experiment is that
I can check if my assumption is
valid by checking
whether I'm actually--
so what I'm going
to do right now
is check whether this is likely
to be a Gaussian or not, right?
And there's two ways
I can violate it.
By violating mean, but also
by violating the variance.
And here, what I did
in the first case,
I said, well I'm not allowing
you to check whether you've
violated the variance.
I'm just plugging whatever
variance you're getting.
Whereas here, I'm
saying, well, there's
two ways you can violate it.
And I'm just going to
factor everything in.
So now I can
plug-in this number.
So this is 80.
This is 0.68.
So I can compute all this stuff.
I can compute all this
stuff here as well.
And what I get in this
case, if I put the xn bar 1,
I get 3.45, OK?
And now I claim
that this makes it
reasonable to reject
the hypothesis that p
is equal to 0.5.
Can somebody tell me why?
STUDENT: It's pretty big.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
3 is pretty big.
So it's very unlikely.
So this number that
I should see should
look like the number I would get
if I asked a computer to draw
one random Gaussian for me.
This number, when I draw
one random Gaussian,
is actually a number with
99.9% this number will
be between negative 3 and 3.
With 78% it's going to be
between negative 2 and 2.
68% is between minus 1 and 1.
And with like 90% it's
between minus 2 and 2.
So getting a 3.45
when you do this
is extremely unlikely
to happen, which
means that you would have to
be extremely unlucky for this
to ever happen.
Now, it can happen, right?
It could be the case that you
flip 80 coins and 80 of them
are heads.
With what probability
does this happen?
1 over 2 to the 80, right?
Which is probably better
off playing the lottery
with this kind of odds, right?
I mean, this is just not going
to happen, but it might happen.
So we cannot remove completely
the uncertainty, right?
It's still possible that
this is due to noise.
But we're just trying to
make all the cases that
are very unlikely go away, OK?
And so, now I claim that 3.45
is very unlikely for a Gaussian.
So if I were to draw the PDF
of a standard Gaussian, right?
So n 0, 1, right?
So that's PDF of n 0, 1.
3.73 is basically here, OK?
So it's just too
far in the tails.
Understood?
Now I cannot say that the
probability that the Gaussian
is equal to 373 is small, right?
I just cannot say
that, because it's 0.
And it's also 0 for the
probability that it's 0,
even though the most
likely values are around 0.
It's the continuous
random variable.
Any value you give
me, it's going
to happen with probability zero.
So what we're going to say
is, well, the fluctuations
are larger than this number.
The probability that
I get anything worse
than this is actually
extremely small, right?
Anything worse than this is
just like farther than 3.73.
And this is going to
be what we control.
All right?
So in this case, I claim
that it's quite reasonable
to reject the hypothesis.
Is everybody OK with this?
Everybody find this shocking?
Or everybody has no
idea what's going on?
Do you have any questions?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Regarding
the case of p, where
minus p isn't close to xn.
If you use 1 minus p
as 0.5, then you're
dividing by a larger number
than you would if you used xn.
So it feels like our
true number is not 3.45.
It's something a
little bit smaller
than 3.45 for the distribution
to actually be like 1/2.
Because it seems
like we're adding
an unnecessary extra
error by using xn bar.
And we're adding
an error that makes
it seem that our result was less
likely than it actually was.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
And you're right.
I didn't want to plug-in
the p everywhere,
but you should plug it
in everywhere you can.
That's for sure, OK?
So let's agree on that.
And that's true that it makes
the number a little bigger.
You compute how
much you would get,
we would get if we 0.5 there.
Well, I don't know what
the square root of 80 is.
Can somebody compute quickly?
I'm not asking you to do it.
But what I want is two times
square root of 80 times 0.18.
3.22
OK.
I can make the same
cartoon picture with 3.22.
But you're right.
This is definitely
more accurate.
And I should have done this.
I didn't want to get the
confused message, OK?
All right.
So now here's a second
example that you can think of.
So now I toss it 30 times.
Still in the realm of the
central limit theorem.
I get 13 heads rather than 15.
So I'm actually much closer
to being exactly at half.
So let's see if this
is actually going
to give me a plausible value.
So I get 0.33 in average.
If the truth was 0.5, I would
get something like 0.77.
And now I claim that 0.77
is a plausible realization
for some standard Gaussian, OK?
Now, 0.77 is going to
look like it's here.
So that could very well
be something that just
comes because of randomness.
And again, if you
think about it.
If I told you, you were
expecting 15, you saw 13,
you're happy to put that on
the account of randomness.
Now of course, the
question is going to be,
where do I draw the line?
Right?
Is 12 the right number?
Is 11?
Is 10?
What is it?
So basically, the answer is
it's whatever you want to be.
The problem it's hard to
think on the scale, right?
What does it mean to
think on the scale?
If I can't think
in this scale, I'm
going to have to think on
the scale of 80 of them.
I'm going to have to think on
the scale of running 100 coin
flips.
And so, this scale is a
moving target all the time.
Every time you
have a new problem,
you have to have a
new skill in mind.
And it's very difficult.
The purpose of
statistical analysis,
and in particular this
process that content
that takes your x
bar and turns it
into something that should
be standard Gaussian,
allows you to map
the value of x bar
into a scale that is the
standard scale of the Gaussian.
All right?
Now, all you need
to have in mind
is, what is a large number
or an unusually large number
for a Gaussian?
That's all you need to know.
So here, by the way,
0.77 is not this one,
because it was
actually negative 0.77.
So this one.
OK.
So I can be on the right or
I can be on the left of zero.
But they are still plausible.
So understand you could
actually have in mind
all the values that are
plausible for a Gaussian
and those that
are not plausible,
and draw the line based on what
you think is the right number.
So how large should a positive
value of a Gaussian to become
unreasonable for you?
Is it 1?
Is it 1.5?
Is it 2?
Stop me when I get there.
Is it 2.5?
Is it 3?
STUDENT: I think 2.5
is definitely too big.
PROFESSOR: What?
STUDENT: Doesn't it
depend on our prior?
Let's say we already
have really good evidence
at this point [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so this
is not Bayesian statistics.
So there's no such thing
as a prior right now.
We'll get there.
You'll have your moment
during one short chapter.
So there's no prior here, right?
It's really a matter
of whether you think
is a Gaussian large or not.
It's not a matter of coins.
It's not a matter of anything.
Now I've just reduced
it to just one question.
So forget about
everything we just said.
And I'm asking you,
when do you decide
that a number is too large
to be reasonably drawn
from a Gaussian?
And this number is 2 or 1.96.
And that's basically the number
that you get from this quintel.
We've seen the
1.96 before, right?
It's actually q alpha over 2,
where alpha is equal to 5%.
That's a quintel of a Gaussian.
So actually, what we
do is we map it again.
So are now at the Gaussians.
And then we map it again
into some probabilities,
which is the probability of
being farther than this thing.
And now probabilities,
we can think.
Probability is something
that quantifies my error.
And the question is
what percentage of error
am I willing to tolerate.
And if I tell you
5%, that's something
you can really envision.
What it means is that if I
were to do this test a million
times, 5% of the time
I would expose myself
to making a mistake.
All right.
That's all it would say.
If you said, well, I don't
want to account for 5%,
maybe I want 1%, then you
have to move from 1.94 to 2.5.
And then if you say
at I want 0.01%,
then you have to move to
an even larger number.
So it depends.
But stating this
number 1%, 5%, 10%
is much easier than seeing those
numbers 1.96, 2.5, et cetera.
So we're just putting
everything back on the scale.
All right.
To conclude, this,
again, as we said,
does not suggest that
the coin is unfair.
Now, it might be that
We just don't have enough
evidence to say that.
And that goes back to
your question about,
why are we siding with
the fact that we're
making it harder to conclude
that the runners were faster?
And this is the same thing.
We're making it
harder to conclude
that the coin is biased.
Because there is a status quo.
And we're trying to
see if we have evidence
against the status quo.
The status quo for the runners
is they ran the same speed.
The status quo for the coin,
we can probably all agree
is that the coin is fair.
The status quo for a drug?
I mean, again,
unless you prove me
that you're actually
not a scammer
is that the status quo is
that this is maple syrup.
There's nothing in there.
Why would you?
I mean, if I let you
get away with it,
you would put corn syrup.
It's cheaper.
OK.
So now let's move on to math.
All right.
So when I started
doing mathematics,
I'm going to have to talk
about random variables
and statistical models.
And here, there is actually
a very simple thing,
which actually goes
back to this picture.
A test is really asking
me if my parameter
is in some region
of the parameter set
or another region of the
parameter set, right?
Yes/no.
And so, what I'm going to be
given is a sample, x1, xn.
I have a model.
And again, those can be
braces depending on the day.
And so, now I'm going to give
myself theta 0 and theta 1
to this joint subset.
OK.
So capital theta
here is the space
in which my parameter can live.
To make two disjoint
subsets, I could just
split this guy in half, right?
I'm going to say, well, maybe
it's this guy and this guy.
OK.
So this is theta 0.
And this is theta 1.
What it means when I split
those two guys, in test,
I'm actually going to focus
only on theta 0 or theta 1.
And so, it means that
a priori I've already
removed all the possibilities
of theta being in this region.
What does it mean?
Go back to the
example of runners.
This region here for
the Cherry Blossom Run
is the set of parameters,
where mu was larger
than 103.5, right?
We removed that.
We didn't even consider
this possibility.
We said either it's less--
sorry.
That's mu equal to 103.5.
And this was mu
less than 103.5, OK?
But these guys were like
if it happens, it happens.
I'm not making any
statement about that case.
All right?
So now I take those two subsets.
And now I'm going to give
them two different names,
because they're going to
have an asymmetric role.
h0 is the null hypothesis.
And h1 is the
alternative hypothesis.
h0 is the status quo.
h1 is what is
considered typically
as scientific discovery.
So if you're a regulator,
you're going to push towards h0.
If you're a scientist, you're
going to push towards h1.
If you're a
pharmaceutical company,
you're going to push towards h1.
OK?
And so, depending on whether you
want to be conservative-- oh,
I can find evidence
in a lot of data.
As soon as you give
me three data points,
I'm going to be able
to find evidence.
That means I'm going to
tend to say, oh, it's h1.
But if you say you
need a lot of data
before you can actually move
away from the status quo,
that's age h0, OK?
So think of h0 as
being status quo,
h1 being some discovery that
goes against the status quo.
All right?
So if we believe that
the truth theta is either
in one of those, what we say is
we want to test h0 against h1.
OK.
This is actually wording.
So remember, because this
is how your questions are
going to be formulated.
And this is how you want
to probably communicate
as a statistician.
So you're going to
say I have the null
and I have an alternative.
I want to test h0 against h1.
I want to test the
null hypothesis
against the alternative
hypothesis, OK?
Now, the two hypotheses I
forgot to say are actually this.
h0 is that the theta
belongs to theta 0.
And h1 is that it theta
belongs to theta 1.
OK.
So here, for example,
theta was mu.
And that was mu equal to 103.5.
And this was mu less than 103.5.
OK?
So typically, they're not going
to look like thetas and things
like that.
They're going to look like very
simple things, where you take
your usual notation for
your usual parameter
and you just say in mathematical
terms what relationship this
should be satisfying, right?
For example, in
the drug example,
that would be mu drug
is equal to mu control.
And here, that would be mu
drug less than mu control.
The number of
expectorations for people
who take the drug
for the cough syrup
is less than the number
of expectoration of people
who take the corn syrup, OK?
So now what we want to do.
We've set up our
hypothesis testing problem.
You're a scientist.
You've set up your problem.
Now what you're going
to do is collect data.
And what you're going to
try to find on this data
is evidence against h0.
And the alternative
is going to guide you
into which direction
you should be looking
for evidence against this guy.
All right?
And so, of course, the
narrower the alternative,
the easier it is for
you, because you just
have to look at the one
possible candidate, right?
But typically, h1 is a
big group, like less than.
Nobody tells you it's
either it's 103.5 and 103.
People tell you it's either
103.5 or less than 103.5.
OK.
And so, what we want to do is
to decide whether we reject h0.
So we look for evidence
against h0 in the data, OK?
So as I said, h0 and h1 do
not play a symmetric role.
It's very important to
know which one you're
going to place as h0
and which one you're
going to place at h1.
If it's a close
call, you're always
going to side with h0, OK?
So you have to be
careful about those.
You have to keep that
in mind that if it's
a close call, if data does
not carry a lot of evidence,
you're going to side with h0.
And so, you're actually
never saying that h0 is true.
You're just saying I did not
find evidence against h0.
You don't say I accept that h0.
You say I failed to reject h0.
OK.
And so one of the
things that you
want to keep in mind
when you're doing this
is this innocent
until proven guilty.
So if you come from a
country, like America,
there's such a thing.
And in particular,
lack of evidence
does not mean that you
are not guilty, all right?
OJ Simpson was found not guilty.
It was not found innocent, OK?
And so, this is
basically what happens
is like the prosecutor
brings their evidence.
And then the jury has
to decide whether they
were convinced that this
person was guilty of anything.
And the question is, do
you have enough evidence?
But if you don't
have evidence, it's
not the burden of the defender
to prove that they're innocent.
Nobody's proving their innocent.
I mean, sometimes it helps.
But you just have to make
sure that there's not
enough evidence against you, OK?
And that's basically
what it's doing.
You're h0 until proven h1.
So how are we going to do this?
Well, as I said, the
role of estimators
in hypothesis testing is played
by something called tests.
And a test is a statistic.
Can somebody remind me
what a statistic is?
Yep?
STUDENT: The measure [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
actually just one step more.
So it's a function
of the observations.
And we require it
to be measurable.
And as a rule of
thumb, measurable
means if I give you data, you
can actually compute it, OK?
If you don't see a
[INAUDIBLE] or an [INAUDIBLE],,
you don't have to
think about it.
All right.
And so, what we do is
we just have this test.
But now I'm actually
asking only from this test
a yes/no answer, which I
can code as 0, 1, right?
So as a rule of thumb, you
say that, well, the test
is equal to 0 then h0.
The test is equal to 1 at h1.
And as we said, is that
if the test is equal to 0,
it doesn't mean
that a 0 is truth.
It means that I
feel to rejected h0.
And if the test is
equal to 1, I reject h0.
So I have two possibilities.
I look at my data.
I turn it into a yes/no answer.
And yes/no answer is
really h0 or h1, OK?
Which one is the most
likely basically.
All right.
So in the coin flip
example, our test statistic
is actually something
that takes value 0, 1.
And anything, any function
that takes value at 0,
1 is an indicator function, OK?
So an indicator function
is just a function.
So there's many ways
you can write it.
So it's a 1 with a double bar.
If you aren't
comfortable with this,
it's totally OK to write i
of something, like i of a.
OK.
And that's what?
So a, here, is a statement,
like an inequality, an equality,
some mathematical statement, OK?
Or not mathematical.
I mean, "a" can be, you know,
my grandma is 20 years old, OK?
And so, this is basically 1 if
a is true, and 0 if a is false.
That's the way you
want to think about it.
This function takes only
two values, and that's it.
So here's the
example that we had.
We looked at whether
the standardized xn
bar, the one that actually
is approximately n 0,1
was larger than something
in absolute value,
either very large or
very small, but negative.
I'm going back to this picture.
We wanted to know
if this guy was
either to the left of something
or to the right of something,
right?
Was it in these regions?
Now this indicator, I can view
this as a function of x bar.
What it does, it really
splits the possible values
of x bar, which is just
a real number, right?
In two groups.
The groups on which they
lead to a value, which is 1.
And the groups on
which they lead
to value, which is 0, right?
So what it does is that
I can actually think
of it as the real line, x bar.
And there's basically
some values here,
where I'm going to get a 1.
Maybe I'm going to get a 0 here.
Maybe I'm going to get a 0.
Maybe I'm going to get a 1.
I'm just splitting all
possible values of x bar.
And I see whether to spit
out the side which is 0
or which is 1.
In this case, it's
not clear, right?
I mean, the function
is very nonlinear.
It's x bar minus 0.5 divided
by the square root of x bar 1
minus x bar.
If we put the p in
the denominator,
that would be clear.
That would just be exactly
something that looks like this.
The function would be like this.
It would be 1 if it's
smaller than some value.
Less than 0 if it's
in between two values.
And then 1 again.
So that's psi, OK?
So this is 1, right?
This is 1.
And this is 0.
So if x bar is too small
or if x bar is too large,
then I'm getting a value 1.
But if it's somewhere in
between, I'm getting a value 0.
Now, if I have this
weird function,
it's not clear
how this happened.
So the picture
here that I get is
that I have a weird
non-linear function, right?
So that's x bar.
That's square root
of n x bar n 0.5
divided by the square root of
x bar n 1 minus x bar n, right?
That's this function.
A priori, I have no idea what
this function looks like.
We can probably
analyze this function,
but let's pretend we don't know.
So it's like some
crazy stuff like this.
And all I'm asking is
whether in absolute value
it's larger than c, which means
that is this function larger
than c or less than minus c?
The intervals on which
I'm going to say 1
are this guy, this guy,
this guy, and this guy.
OK.
And everywhere
else, I'm seeing 0.
Everybody agree with this?
This is what I'm doing.
Now of course, it's
probably easier for you
to just package it into
this nice thing that's
just either larger than
c, an absolute value,
or less Than C. I want to
have to plot this function.
In practice, you don't have to.
Now, this is where I
am actually claiming.
So here, I actually
defined to you a test.
And I promised, starting
this lecture, by saying,
oh, now we're going
to do something better
than computing the averages.
Now I'm telling you it's
just computing an average.
And the thing is
the test is not just
the specification of this x bar.
It's also the specification
of this constant c.
All right?
And the constant c
was exactly where
our belief about what a large
value for a Gaussian is.
That's exactly where it came in.
So this choice of c is
basically a threshold
at which we decide above
this threshold this isn't
likely to come from a Gaussian.
Below this threshold
we decide that it's
likely to come from a Gaussian.
So we have to choose what
this threshold is based
on what we think likely means.
Just a little bit
more of those things.
So now we're going to
have to characterize
what makes a good test, right?
Well, I'll come back
to it in a second.
But you could have a test
that says reject all the time.
And that's going to
be bad test, right?
The FDA is not
implementing a test
that says, yes all drugs work,
now let's just go to Aruba, OK?
So people are trying
to have something that
tries to work all the time.
Now FDA's not either
saying, let's just
say that no drugs work, and
let's go to Aruba, all right?
They're just trying
to say the right thing
as often as possible.
And so, we're going to
have to measure this.
So the things that are
associated to a test
are the rejection region.
And if you look at this
x in en, such that psi
of x is equal to 1, this is
exactly this guy that I drew.
So here, I summarized
the values of the sample
into their average.
But the values of the
sample that I collect
will lead to a test that says 1.
All right?
So this is the rejection region.
If I collect a data point,
technically I have--
so I have e to the n, which
is a big space like this.
So that's e to the n.
Think of it as being
the space of xn bars.
And I have a function that
takes only value 0, 1.
So I can decompose
it into this part
where it takes value 0 and the
part where it takes value 1.
And those can be super
complicated, right?
Can have a thing like this.
Can have some weird little
islands where it takes value 1.
I can have some islands
where it's takes value 0.
I can have some
weird stuff going on.
But I can always partition
it into the value
where it takes value 0 and the
value where it takes value 1.
And the value where it takes
1, if psi is equal to 1,
this is called the rejection
region of the plot, OK?
So just the samples that
would lead me to rejecting.
And notice that this is the
indicator of the rejection
region.
The test is the indicator
of the rejection region.
So there's two ways you can make
an error when there's a test.
Either the truth is in h1, and
you're saying actually it's h1.
Or the truth is in h1,
and you say it's h0.
And that's how we build-in the
asymmetry between h0 and h1.
We control only one
of the two errors.
And we hope for the
best for the second one.
So the type 1 error is
the one that says, well,
if it is actually the
status quo, but a claim
that there is a discovery--
if it's actually h0,
but I claim that
I'm in h1, then I
admit I commit a type I error.
And so the probability
of type I error
is this function
alpha of psi, which
is the probability of saying
that psi is equal to 1
when theta is in h0.
Now, the problem is that
this is not just number,
because theta is just like
moving all over h0, right?
There's many values that
theta can be, right?
So theta is somewhere here.
I erased it, OK.
All right.
For simplicity, we're
going to think of theta
as being mu and 103.5, OK?
And so, I know that
this is theta 1.
And just this point
here was theta 0, OK?
Agreed?
This is with the
Cherry Blossom Run.
Now, here in this case,
it's actually easy.
I need to compute
this function alpha
of psi, which maps theta in
theta 0 to p theta of psi
equals 1.
So that's the probability that
I reject when theta is in h0.
Then there's only one
of them to compute,
because theta can only
take this one value.
So this is really 103.5.
OK.
So that's the
probability that I reject
when the true mean was 103.5.
Now, if I was testing whether--
if h0 was this entire
guy here, all the
values larger than
103.5, then I would
have to compute this function
for all possible values
of the theta in there.
And guess what?
The worst case is when
it's going to be here.
Because it's so close
to the alternative
that that's where I'm making
the most error possible.
And then there's
the type 2 error,
which is defined basically
in the symmetric ways.
The function that maps
theta to the probability.
So that's the probability
of type 2 errors.
The probability that I
fail to reject h0, right?
If psi is equal to 0,
I fail to reject h0.
But that actually
came from h1, OK?
So in this example, let's clear.
If I'm here, like if
the true mean was 100,
I'm looking at the probability
that the true mean is actually
100, and I'm actually
saying it was 103.5.
Or it's not less than 103.5.
Yeah?
STUDENT: I'm just still
confused by the notation.
When you say that [INAUDIBLE]
theta sub 1 arrow r,
I'm not sure what
that notation means.
PROFESSOR: Well, this
just means it's a function
that maps theta 0 to r.
You've seen functions, right?
OK.
So that's just
the way you write.
So that means that's a function
f that goes from, say, r r,
and that maps x to x squared.
OK.
So here, I'm just saying
I don't have to consider
all possible values.
I'm only considering
the values on theta 0.
I put r actually.
I could restrict myself
to the interval 0, 1,
because those are probabilities.
So it's just telling me
where my function comes from
and where my function goes to.
And beta is a function, right?
So beta psi of theta
is just the probability
that theta is equal to 1.
And I could define
that for all thetas--
sorry.
If psi is equal
to 0 in this case.
And that could define
that for all thetas.
But the only ones
that lead to an error
are the thetas that are in h1.
I mean, I can define
this function.
It's just not going to
correspond to an error, OK?
And the power of a
test is the smallest--
so the power is basically
1 minus an error.
1 minus the probability
of an error.
So it's the probability of
making a correct decision, OK?
making a correct decision
under h1, that's
what the power is.
But again, this
could be a function.
Because there's many
ways that can be in h1
if h1 is an entire
set of numbers.
For example, all the numbers
there are less than 103.5.
And so, what I'm doing here when
I define the power of a test,
I'm looking at the smallest
possible of those values, OK?
So I'm looking at this function.
Maybe I should actually
expand a little more on this.
OK.
So beta psi of theta is
the probability under theta
that psi is equal to 0, right?
That's the probability
in theta 1,
which means then the
alternative, that they
feel to reject.
And I really should,
because theta
was actually in theta 1, OK?
So this thing here is the
probability of type 2 error.
Now, this is 1 minus the
probability that I did reject
and I should have rejected.
That's just a little
off the complement.
Because if psi is not equal
to 0, then it's equal to 1.
So now if I rearrange
this, it tells me
that the probability
that psi is equal to 1--
this is actually 1
minus beta psi of theta.
So that's true for
all thetas in theta 1.
And what I'm saying
is, well, this
is now a good thing, right?
This number being
large is a good thing.
It means I should have
rejected, and I rejected.
I want this to happen
with large probability.
And so, what I'm
going to look at
is the most conservative
choice of this number, right?
Rather than being
super optimistic
and say, oh, but indeed if theta
was actually equal to zero,
then I'm always going
to conclude that--
I mean, if mu is equal to 0,
everybody runs in 0 seconds,
then I with high
probability I'm actually
going to make no mistake.
But really, I should look at
the worst possible case, OK?
So what I'm looking
at is basically
the smallest value it
can take on theta one
is called power of psi.
Power of the test psi, OK?
So that's the smallest
possible value it can take.
All right.
So I'm sorry.
This is a lot of definitions
that you have to sink in.
And it's not super pleasant.
But that's what testing is.
There's a lot of jargon.
Those are actually
fairly simple things.
Just maybe you should
get a sheet for yourself.
And say, these are the
new terms that I learned.
What is their test,
rejection region?
Probably of type
I error, probably
of type 2 error, and power.
Just make sure you know
what those guys are.
Oh.
And null and alternative
hypothesis, OK?
And once you know
all these things,
you know what I'm talking about.
You know what I'm referring to.
And this is just jargon.
But in the end, those
are just probabilities.
I mean, these a
natural quantities.
Just for some reason,
people have been used
to using different terminology.
So just to illustrate.
When do I make a typo 1 error?
And when do I not
make a type 1 error?
So I make a type 1 error if h0
is true and I reject h0, right?
So the off diagonal blocks
are when I make an error.
When I'm on the diagonal
terms, h1 is true
and I reject h0, that's
a correct decision.
When h0 is true and
I fail to reject h0,
that's also the correct
decision to make.
So I only make errors when
I'm in one of the red blocks.
And one block is the type
1 error and the other block
is the type 2 error.
That's all it means, OK?
So you just have to know
which one we called one.
I mean, this was chosen
in a pretty ad hoc way.
So to conclude this lecture,
let me ask you a few questions.
If in a US court, the
defendant is found either say,
let's just say for the sake of
discussion, innocent or guilty.
All right?
It's really guilty
for not guilty,
but let's say
innocent or guilty.
When does the jury
make a type 1 error?
Yep?
And he's guilty?
And he's innocent, right?
The status quo, everybody is
innocent until proven guilty.
So that's our h0 is that
the person is innocent.
And so, that means
that h0 is innocent.
And so, we're looking at the
probably of type 1 error,
so that's when we reject
the fact that it's innocent.
So conclude that this
person is guilty, OK?
So type 1 error is when
this person is innocent
and we conclude it's guilty.
What is the type 2 error?
Letting a guilty
person go free, which
actually according
to the constitution,
is the better of the two.
All right?
So what we're going to try to
do is to control the first one,
and hope for the best
for the second one.
How could the jury make sure
that they make no type 1
error ever?
Always let the guy
go free, right?
What is the effect
on the type 2 error?
Yeah, it's the worst
possible, right?
I mean, basically, for every guy
that's guilty, you let them go.
That's the worst you can do.
And same thing, right?
How can the jury make sure
that there's no type 2 error?
Always convict.
What is the effect on
the American budget?
What is the effect
on the type 1 error?
Right.
So the effect is that basically
the type 1 error is maximized.
So there's this trade
off between type 1
and type 2 error
that's inherent.
And that's why we have this
sort of multi objective thing.
We're trying to minimize
two things at the same time.
And I can't find many
ad hoc ways, right?
So if you've taken
any optimization,
trying to optimize two
things when one is going up
while the other one is going
down, the only thing you can do
is make ad hoc heuristics.
Maybe you try to minimize
the sum of those two guys.
1/3 of the first guy
plus 2/3 of the second guy.
Maybe you try to minimize
the first guy plus the square
of the second guy.
You can think of many
ways, but none of them
is more justified
than the other.
However, for statistical
hypothesis testing,
there's one that's very well
justified, which is just
constrain your type 1
error to be the smallest,
to be at a level that
you deem acceptable.
5%.
I want to convict at most
5% of innocent people.
That's what I deem reasonable.
And based on that, I'm going to
try to convict as many people
as they can, all right?
So that's called the
Nieman Pearson paradigm,
and we'll talk
about it next time.
All right.
Thank you.